power foes power pose alright welcome to  today's video today this is a personal  one for me this is my old alarm clock  it used to be set the infrared beam from  my xbox remote used to actually turn the  alarm on so I stopped working up at  ridiculous hours in the morning to this  annoying  beeping wasn't really a fan of this too  especially at 4:00 in the morning  so let's shut it up give me that  shut up look at the way it updates the  screen that's weird it's like half of it  and then the other half there's  obviously not enough processing power to  show the whole the whole time at once  all right let's kill it I'm sick of it  damn it haha good well I enjoyed that  get back tomorrow there'll be another  watch - what's tomorrow Friday let's do  a TV tomorrow let's catch up